les trottinettes électriques ont libre
service c'est bientôt fini consultez
hier par référendum les Parisiens ont
massivement rejeté leur usage je suis
engagé bien sûr à respecter purement et
simplement le résultat du vote le contre
l'emporte après de 90% un résultat
annuant ces tout de même l'abstention a
été très forte seule 7,5% des Parisiens
ont participé à cette votation cette
vidéo aurait été filmée par un habitant
la scène remonte au 24 mars dernier dans
le quartier des Moulins à Nice c'est le
député des Alpes-Maritimes ericsiotique
qu'il a partagé hier cet après-midi nous
parlons de cette nuit meurtrière à
Marseille dans le milieu du banditisme
lié au trafic de drogue en trois points
de la cité phocéenne des règlements de
comptes ont fait un carnage sur ce
trottoir d'un quartier près du port ce
sont des adolescents qui ont été pris
pour cible vers minuit par des hommes en
voiture monsieur Darmanin veut remplacer
madame borne à Matignon tout le monde
l'a compris et donc pour essayer de se
singulariser
il va dans les outrances qui sont tout à
fait insupportables
quelle sera la prochaine étape
énormément de parodie circule
Dupond-Moretti dans le sanglier magazine
Bruno Le Maire dans Picoti ah on est
prêt à tout sur Twitter je vous préviens
que vous trouvez Mike fly et Carlito
c'est mieux que qu'elle va faire dans
Playboy ou des ministres ou un ou le
directeur de cabinet de Brigitte Macron
qui paraît-il s'évanouit sur un trottoir
parce qu'il est abîmé Elisabeth borne
qui pourrait tout dévoiler dans Picsou
Magazine la première ministre a pour
tâche ardu d'apaiser les tensions après
le passage en force sur la réforme des
retraites elle convient à Matignon les
chefs de party et de groupe
parlementaires et ça commence
aujourd'hui par une rencontre avec le
groupe liotte qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de cette rencontre avec la
première ministre bah le retrait de la
réforme des retraites c'est simple donc
ça peut être très court elle a déjà dit
que ce serait non bah du coup je pense
que notre réponse va être très rapide le
rendez-vous si si c'est ça le
rendez-vous risque d'être très rapide
sur France Inter je peux pas y aller
mais même Léa Salamé elle me l'a quand
j'étais invité sur France 2 elle me l'a
dit dans le couloir elle m'a dit bah non
c'est vrai je sais je peux pas vous dire
le contraire voilà bon attendez Léa
Salamé vous bien sûr la maladie et vous
êtes dit ça ça va être repris moi je
serai à l'écoute de tous les sujets que
les organisations syndicales voudront
aborder moi j'ai entendu la nouvelle
secrétaire général de la CGT ce matin a
expliqué qu'il y avait pas d'autres
sorties de l'impasse possible que le
retrait de la réforme je suis
entièrement d'accord avec elle et on
continuera de le dire tant qu'il le faut
mais le temps de la première ministre
est clairement compté notamment selon
ses plus proches collaborateurs il y a
une ambiance à mi-chemin entre
l'anesthésie et le crépuscule Elisabeth
borne Emmanuel Macron se sont eux-mêmes
Nasser dans une voie sans issue la seule
issue possible à la crise actuelle c'est
qu'il retire cette contre-réforme des
retraites on le sait tous la probabilité
qu'elle reste est très mince
Borny arrivera pas
est-ce qu'elle est cuite
non pas tout à fait enfin elle est sur
la poêle
pour les 184 membres de la Convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie pas de doute
il faut faire évoluer la loi
76% d'entre eux sont pour la dactive à
mourir 23% contre ils ont remis leur
rapport hier avec 146 propositions nous
n'avons pas le choix entre une société
où l'exigence de mourir dans la dignité
et légitimement devenu commune et où
l'insuffisance de l'offre de soins
palliatifs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plaqué au sol sur le terrain par le
service de sécurité Ricardo fan des
Dodger ceux de Los Angeles a été menotté
puis escorté à l'extérieur du stade et
aujourd'hui il est officiellement fiancé
[Musique]
je souhaite que ce travail permet de
bâtir un projet de loi d'ici à la fin de
l'été 2023